[MUSIC PLAYING]
ANTHONY SULLIVAN: Mobile
is hugely important to us
at "The Guardian."
So mobile is our future.
Like many publishers, we're
seeing a huge transition
of our audience onto
mobile platforms.
So what we see is our
apps users consume
vastly more content than
any other user that we have,
actually.
Android is clearly
a huge part of that.
TOM GRINSTED: It's
not overstating
it to say that our apps users,
including our Android users,
are our most valuable users
across the entire portfolio.
They read more of our content.
They stick around for longer
and spend more time with us.
App users are between
10 and 20 times
more engaged than
the average web user.
Native apps like our
Android app provide features
that you can't get
on the mobile web.
And really, this comes
down to key things
around ever presence.
The fact that once you're on
the device, you're always there
and you're running-- that
gives us opportunities
that we've never had before.
If you look at our
Android web integration,
for instance, then that's
really about enabling people
to receive "Guardian"
notifications in a much more
timely and interesting way.
And then to be able to read them
straightaway, or even save them
for later if they get a story
that they really care about,
but they're in a situation where
they can't quite read it yet.
I'm really proud
of the team here,
and have opt-in
rate of over 90%.
So fewer than 10%
of people choose
not to get our notifications.
And that really
speaks to the quality
of the editorial choices
that we make around them.
With such a large
audience for our apps,
then personalization become
increasingly important.
You can personalize
your homepage.
And this is a really,
really powerful feature.
It allows users to select
any kind of content
from across the entire network.
So it could be your
favorite subject,
it could be your
favorite writer.
And we want to make sure the
content that's relevant to them
is really front and center
for their experience.
ANTHONY SULLIVAN: Having engaged
users is critically important.
In fact, in many ways it's
more important than just having
a large number of users
for "The Guardian."
And creating a habit, that's
really important to us.
So that not only helps
us with monetization,
but building that really sort
of long lifetime relationship
with the audience.
TOM GRINSTED: As a business,
we passionately believe
that the only way to be
confident about the products
we're going to launch is to test
them, test them, test them--
and get them in front of as many
real readers and real users as
possible.
We do that through Google Play,
through replying to reviews.
We do that through the
Android beta program.
Now, the reason we do
all of those things,
it's because we really
want to understand
what they're doing
with our products.
And what they're
finding difficult,
and what they're loving.
That kind of feedback does help
us make strategic decisions
about what's most
important for our readers
when they're using the app.
A good example is the new
search that we're releasing.
It's a direct
response to feedback
we've got both from our beta
program, and on Google Play
as well.
Mobile on Android has played
a key part in our growth
strategy, both in
emerging markets
and mature markets as well.
When we look at
our new markets--
so India is a really
good example-- then
people there are going
straight to mobile.
And Android is a
large part of that.
So our work on Android is part
of our international growth.